good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Monday hope everyone
had a fabulous fabulous weekends hey Jax
how you doing I'm darn good I personally
am one of those who had a fabulous
weekend it was my birthday this weekend
as most of you know I was in New York it
was just so incredib
I don't even know where to begin
yesterday was my actual birthday and I
flew home and I don't identify with
yesterday as my birthday like my
birthday was Friday Saturday and it was
everything and more
no like I can't lie to you waking up
yesterday like the fact that it was your
birthday like was not top of mind for me
because it had been your birthday for
like four days right and it wasn't top
of mind for me either like I wasn't
looking for anything like I got all my
birthday celebrations out so yesterday
was just a travel day and then I came
home and I did get to celebrate with the
Shapiro's and that was really special so
that felt like birthday but it was an
amazing weekend you guys like
I just had such a ball
I had a ball too like we did so many
activities for your B-day
um of course Saturday night like we went
to the club mcclurbia went to the club
which isn't crazy but Jackie O also went
to the club now I can't lie she didn't
stay the whole time but
she was at the club and the club was not
okay I was at the club you guys made a
shrewd move by choosing a restaurant
that is on top of a club like so it
really cost me nothing to go plus we
went to Acme which plays really good
music most of the time so I was in the
mood to listen to music do a little
dance make a little love you know get
down tonight like I wouldn't have wanted
to be like at the clubs in Ibiza
listening to house music beats but to
listen to some good Tunes with some
great gals it was a great night I mean
dinner was the highlight of my night and
the biggest chunk of my night we went to
a fabulous new restaurant called The
Nines and it was just
like it was really a perfect New York
City weekend and that was a perfect New
York City night yeah also I loved the
weekend because it was a great combo my
favorite trips are trips where I'm like
working and playing because then I feel
like I'm not just productive laying
around like uh
stick voiceless person stick Place AKA
useless person so it was so productive
we did toast we had the Amazon event
then we had like so much fun I got to
see all my friends we partied down we
had so much family time you know it was
Autumn in New York which is the best
season in New York
except like it's literally 70 80 degrees
here I was just having this conversation
like you know it's the first week of
November a lot of people are putting up
their Christmas trees which I totally
endorse like the second Halloween is
over if I was celebrating Christmas like
my ass would be decorating at midnight
but to put up a Christmas tree and then
go outside and it's 75 degrees like it's
so unnatural to me it's so [ __ ] hot
here like it has to stop yeah Saturday
Saturday was a little warm for me
given that I was looking forward to a
New York chill but I won't complain no
in NYC and New York chill and why see
it was really an amazing weekend Time
Square thank you so much for celebrating
your birthday here with us we enjoyed it
immensely I had a fabulous time I hope
you feel celebrated and I hope you feel
30. you're 30 flirty and thriving I do I
feel so fulfilled I I want for nothing
more for my birthday thank you to
everyone
okay wait so now
um that you're 30.
is it everything like Jenna rank said it
would be
I definitely feel 30.
flirty question mark I don't know no and
thriving yes I do but she was a
different sort of 30 like she was 30
flirty and thriving you know she was
dating hockey players she was running
around town and I just I feel like
30 fulfilled and thriving
yeah like in terms of her career Jenna
rank was definitely 30 but in terms of
her social life she was acting more like
a 22 year old you know no not 22 because
like she was acting in a mature way she
was acting like a 26 year old
yeah yeah I guess
um truckers for General so
truckers for generic are outside I'm a
trucker for generank that's for damn big
time Big Time Magazine editor
um however I wanted to say that in
addition to obviously spending so much
wonderful time with you this weekend I
also consumed a lot of content I watch
the Selena Gomez documentary and I know
we have a story about Selena so I'm
gonna put my thoughts on the documentary
in the story and I just want to say like
it's not whatever like I completely
disagree with what everyone's saying
about this documentary I have some
pretty pretty harsh thoughts and you
know I'm like a Selena girly now so I'm
I'm coming at this from like a place of
love I'm looking forward to it and I
haven't seen the documentary so I'm not
going to speak on it as much but the
vibe that I'm getting from what I've
seen is that
it's lacking in certain areas
um and we'll get into it and I do look
forward to hearing your thoughts it
might corroborate what I was feeling
basically definitely thought it was
lacking in many areas and I think what
people are taking away from the
documentary is so wrong like they're
focusing on the wrong things
um so we'll dive into it when we talk
about the Francia Raisa stuff which like
has is just a pop culture story that I
will never stop being interested in yeah
I guess I could ask you the question we
do the story but might as well ask now
were they friends before Francia was
famous and then like Francia became
people like are they home friends or
fame friends
I believe that they're Fame friends but
like that makes it even crazier this
story then no Selena like fully um like
didn't mention her in the documentary
and it was part of the reason yes but I
didn't I'll explain my confusion after I
for some reason thought they were home
friends and then Francia like became an
actress on her own after being a friend
of Selena
no there's really not a lot of like
background on how the two know each
other that's why when we all found out
that Francia was the one who gave her a
kidney we were all like what yeah and
Francia was in life size too
life size two sorry number two oh not
not life-size comma two not life-sized
as well
got it okay
um well I didn't know that and I didn't
see life size too so I truly don't care
big difference
you
um I also watched Love is Blind I know
you're obsessed I'm obsessed because
like it's really such a good show and I
think like I lost a lot of faith in the
series after season two because it was
so [ __ ] bad
um but this season like they found just
like a crazy delusional honestly unwell
group of people specifically the men and
it's making for some wonderful
television they are dropping episodes
episodically which is like what why
really why like we all moved on from
episodic drops thanks to Netflix and now
Netflix is bringing it back and now
Hulu's doing it and it's [ __ ]
disrespectful it's messed up Netflix
invented binging like they created
addicts and now they're taking it away
when we need it more than ever like we
don't know how to function without binge
watching shows it affected how we watch
shows you know Sunday night on ABC like
that doesn't happen anymore because
we're addicts of the binge and now you
just wanna
bring back healthy take that away bring
back healthy habits I don't think so
healthy habits not interested healthy
habits less than unhealthy habits
healthy habits I don't know her
um I do want to update everyone just
like a quick Wellness update I'm feeling
much better than I was on the episode on
Friday thank you to everyone who was
um patient with me
um my lack of energy you know I do have
like a little bit of like a stuffy nose
and now I'm thinking like maybe I was
getting sick I'm fine
um it was just like a low energy day
everyone has them not everyone has
billions of people watching depending on
your energy right that's obviously
different but I'm feeling much better
they're energy dependent
I don't know what got into me on Friday
but I'm feeling much better it was a fry
nay oh not the fried egg because it
wasn't a fry yay and it wasn't a stride
day and I think that therein lies the
problem
therein heretofore
moving forward lies the problem a
problem has arisen
problem
s
I couldn't keep going it's tight it has
to end at some point
unfortunately yes it does unfortunately
um so we've got a great show we've got
good stories some sad some interesting
um Lots was happening over the weekend
in our personal lives but also in the
lives of others and we can't wait to
dissect it all with you here at the
toast also I don't know if you can see
mclartia because my computer screen is
far away but I am wearing your gift
oh no I didn't see I got Jackie the most
circling you know how we like well
Jackie like found this necklace and I
copied her and then I immediately
started acting different made the
necklace like my personality and the
necklace was like you know not real gold
or anything so um for her 30th birthday
I was inspired by that necklace and I
decided you know let's get the real
let's take it up a notch let's take it
up a notch so I got it from this new
like Indie boutique store it's called
Channel I don't know if you guys have
heard of it
um a lot of people actually mix up their
stuff with our merch which is I like I
could see why it really looks similar
um it's from Chanel and it's so second
I'm so glad you're wearing it it's so
sick but like it's not because Chanel
jewelry it's not real gold like it's
still like
metal
I'm sorry like you kept saying like it's
it's um the other necklace wasn't real
gold but this isn't real gold
sorry to call you out
okay first of all like don't be rude no
I'm not trying to be rude just jumpy
[ __ ] rude you ungrateful wench and
two
um
no because that's the point of Chanel
Julie we always say this I mean it's so
cute it I mean I'm obsessed with take
the necklace out of it I'm obsessed with
this necklace I'm wearing it today like
I can't stop look how
look how sickening but the Chanel
jewelry is costume
so then why isn't it like a dollar
because you're paying for the Chanel
name
so
what you're saying is that I've been
hoodwinked but you knew that remember
that time we got earrings
a channel maybe we're like no no they
felt like a low price for something
Chanel but it's actually a high price
for a piece of plastic
though this is in plastic this is real
stuff
am I right am I rocking your world or
insulting you or both
I'm past the insult because now I'm just
like focused on the price that I paid
for
metal
but I think it's um like gold plated
plated yeah
great I didn't look into it
um
but I love it so much
we just didn't want like
anyone to like go into the store and
then be like
they said it was real gold
yeah they said it on that podcast that I
listened to and they're always right
about everything they've never been
wrong they've never been wrong no okay
well enjoy your metal necklace to the
airport anytime soon
no I love it it's literally so sickening
and I'm mostly so flattered that you
didn't keep it for yourself because it's
so you too
so I was literally checking out with
this pink wallet that was like so cute
and so you and like you could really
wear it as like a clutch too it's like a
big wallet
um then I saw the necklace I'm like oh
look something for me and then I was
thinking like if I want to get it for
myself that means it would make an
excellent 30th birthday gift and you
would have liked the wallet and you
would have used it but like it wasn't
that special
I was leaning towards it because it was
like half the price and I was just like
being cheap
um but I feel good I feel good I made
the right decision thank you so much no
I truly I love it I actually I made out
with a um it was a big necklace birthday
for me he made out like a bandit with
everyone yeah I got really great gifts
but all like um I got some really great
necklaces specifically because you're
like a neck when I think of jewelry like
you don't really wear a ton of jewelry
you really just wear
necklaces yeah that's really the only
time I like switch it up uh especially
if I have like my things that I wear
every day but if I'm ever gonna add like
an accent piece to like compliment an
outfit it's only ever going to be a
necklace
oh speaking of I just wanted to like
make a PSA to like all the reporters who
are watching today's episode I did
forget to wear my wedding ring
um
things are fine at home I just forgot
and you know people are always
speculating it's like so exhausting like
can I ask you something like does this
have any do you think that this
forgetting to wear your ring has
anything to do with seeing Tyler see on
Thursday night
I mean I would be remiss to not at least
acknowledge like on some subconscious
level maybe I did you know not put on my
ring for that reason
um but no actually I also watched Amy
Schumer on SNL and the skits were like
actual trash but her opening monologue
was some of the funniest [ __ ] I've ever
heard in my life it was so relatable
because she was talking about how like
you know after she gave birth her doctor
was like no sex for six weeks like
really stressing like no sex till at
least six weeks like you gotta hold off
and she's like oh okay like what about
six years like it's not happening and
then she was talking about like marital
sex and how it's like kind of weird
because like you know in an ideal
marriage you like know your partner so
well you know everything about them
you're so connected they're like family
they're like a brother so it's like
you're gonna [ __ ] your brother
and then she was like you can't even
it's like you know each other so well
you can't even be like sexy talk because
you know your partner's like I'm gonna
and it's like no you're not
no you're not like I know
I know you so well you're not gonna
[ __ ] do that Jackie me and Ben were
cackling it was so funny I actually like
really fell off on Amy Schumer
like I feel like she just like like
wasn't like top of mind for me when it
came to female comedians she was so
[ __ ] funny oh my God it was it was
like brilliant that is so funny one and
two you know Dana's obsessed with Amy
Schumer
um I called her last night to talk and
she was like reciting Amy's jokes she
sees Amy all over town and when Amy
practices her material some of which she
used in the monologue Dana has heard it
five times already right so Dana goes to
every single one of Amy's shows in New
York but a lot of them are at the Comedy
Cellar and sometimes she like pops up at
the comedy seller Dana goes to the
comedy Center all the time in hopes of
seeing Amy and I think and she's like
met her on the like ran into her on the
street a few times I think she has like
two selfies with her but Dana's always
front row at all of her shows that Amy
like knows her face and one time Amy was
doing her set which she's like been
working on and she was doing the punch
line which she's done a lot of times in
front of Dana and she actually gave the
mic to Dana and Dana finished the joke
for her because she knows her set
backwards and forwards
so [ __ ] funny and when I had my Funny
Bone Subway uh panic attack Vitiligo
what's it called yeah something
something like that no Vitiligo I think
that's a skin disease whatever when I
like fainted on the train the same thing
happened to Dana and she was on her way
for to see Amy Schumer she's always on
her way to see Amy Schumer no and you
know what like I totally get the hype oh
my God it was
so funny oh this is what else I was
gonna say about what Amy's monologue is
about which I need to watch but it
reminds me of in this book called in
five years which I don't think you've
ever read but it's a snitch's choice and
we read it for the redheads and she's in
this like long-term relationship and
like things are boring whatever and like
one time in the bed like he does
something new and it like actually set
off a red flag in her head like where
did you learn did you learn this yes
where we don't do that you must have
gotten me confused with your other with
some other [ __ ] yeah so oh man that's
funny that's the other thing if he says
like I'm gonna do this and it's like we
don't do that well right no who are you
doing that with who are you talking to
no it was so funny so Kudos and then
Dave Chappelle is next week on SNL and
that I'm excited about sweet and who was
the musical performer
I had not heard of who was really
stunning and truly truly talented like
it was giving rhythm and blues like
played guitar and he sang I think his
name was Steve Lacy oh cool also it was
good stuff Switching gears for a second
because we've been listening to a lot of
midnights and we had a huge conversation
at dinner about our favorite songs but
there's one song on the album and have
people said to you that there's one song
that sounds like 100 yeah 100 yes maroon
yes maroon
Jackie a lot of people like I know I
sound crazy no no you know that one of
my special skills is listening to a song
and and being able to tell you like what
it sounds what it references what it
references or what it sounds like and
then if you went and listened to both
songs like you would see the
similarities and on my own I came to the
conclusion that maroon 100 are very
sonically similar
no I I know okay I don't want to keep
talking about it because people are
going to be like Claudia you're
literally mental you're not you never by
the way you didn't mention it you
haven't said it on the show I came to
this conclusion on my own
and I got like a thousand DMS from
people who listened to midnights for the
first time they're like I swear to God
when maroon started playing I thought it
was 100 no it's like when she finishes
the first verse it's like
it sounds like what we're about to say
100 yeah but instead she says something
else
100
thank you for bringing that up yeah
welcome
um so we've got a great great great show
all throughout the Great War well let's
quickly talk about what are your
favorites for midnights my favorites
from midnights now that I've you were
playing it a lot while you were here so
it got me familiar with some songs and
then I listened intentionally with my
headphones to the whole album and these
were the ones that I saved
bigger than the whole sky
yes the great Ward
so good Mastermind
so good question
yes even though the chorus makes me
cringe a little bit makes me feel like
I'm in seventh grade like and we're
playing Seven Minutes in Heaven okay and
midnight rain
um honorable mention two you're on your
own kid
you like Paris
and Paris
um so in love that I might stop
breathing through a map in your bedroom
ceiling so good
so good
so good I'm so good
um and we're so good like you know yeah
so now without further I didn't do
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
I dropped my [ __ ] hold on you dropped
your [ __ ]
do it again good because I messed up too
okay now without further Ado here are
the past five stories that you need to
know
picked it up I'm sure the microphone did
oh no now I hear it
all right and I have just so much to do
like my little gadgets don't drop your
cards
today's episode is it's sponsored by
canva for teams creating visual content
is an essential part of what we do here
at the toast but the creative process
hasn't always been that easy you know
Jackie nor I are great or talented
graphic designers we know our skills and
that's not one of them so when it comes
time to making content for social media
for Instagram YouTube thumbnails things
like that it's never really been
something we've gotten
good at until we discovered canva and
were able to be making these most
sickening graphic designs with literally
five minutes so ever since we found
canva for teams it has been easy to
collaborate and design with our team
which makes the whole process so much
more creative and fun canva for teams is
a design platform that makes it easy for
anyone to create stunning content in any
format from social media posts to videos
presentations and websites the endless
templates and premium fonts photos
graphics and videos add personality and
Edge to our team's content and being
able to use like all the different
members of your team using the same
canva account is so great because like
we have all these different templates
for like patreon for guest cards and
sometimes Jackie will make it sometimes
I will make it so we can be working on
the same template
um and seeing each other's changes it's
really smart they also have um featured
designs for brand consistency canva for
teams makes it easy to maintain your
aesthetic you can add your own logos
your own fonts your colors anything you
create so when we rebranded we have
obviously a whole new Brand Story
different logos different colors and we
can import all of that into canva which
is sickening they streamline how we do
our social media we can plan create and
share social content directly to all of
our channels from one place and we can
even schedule posts ahead of time so
collaborate with canva for teams right
now you can get a free 45-day extended
trial when you go to canva dot me slash
toast that's c-a-n-v-a dot m e slash
toast for a free 45 day extended trial
canva dot me slash toast today's episode
is also sponsored by go macro go macro
macro bars are made from simple high
quality ingredients and are packed with
Organic gluten-free deliciousness
they're available in 16 mouthwatering
flavors macro bars
are able to keep you fueled throughout
the day fun fact for the longest time I
thought that it was Goma Crow
um because I'm really not that smart so
macro bars are made from simple high
quality ingredients they are certified
organic vegan vegan gluten-free kosher
non-GMO clean and soy free they make
delicious bars and they also make a
positive change towards a better Planet
they've partnered with terracycle to
create a national recycling program for
the wrappers of the go macro bars once
they're collected terracycle processes
the wrappers back into raw material that
can be used to make items like park
benches playgrounds and deck material I
know you have like a go macro bar pretty
much every day before the toast it's
like your favorite thing ever it is they
are my favorite bars because they are
the only bars that actually make me full
enough like to have as a meal
replacement or as a big snack they're
also so tasty and they're just like
filled with stuff that's actually going
to make you full and not eating like
junk air they are far and away my
favorite bars I've been eating them for
a few years now she would always call
them go macro when I would have them in
the office and now now she's had to say
them properly because I'm so excited
that they are a sponsor
you can get your hands on delicious
plant-based protein bars by going to
gomacro.com and you can use promo code
toast for 30 off plus free shipping on
all orders over fifty dollars so that's
go macro
g-o-m-a-c-r-o.com code toast for 30 off
plus free shipping on all orders over 50
doll hairs great thank you so much
Claudia two premium sponsors so far
canva by the way you're welcome I don't
know if you guys know this but the
redheads are actually powered by canva I
did know that you should put that in
your bio powered by canva yeah maybe we
have a lot going on in our bio we got to
say the new book we gotta explain what
the [ __ ] it is people get no it's so
true the thing about like being a mogul
is on social media is really figuring
out what pertinent information goes into
your bio yeah
so true because I just recently did like
a haul like an overhaul of my bio
because I wanted to include like founder
of Spritz toast News Network host of the
morning toast
um but then also like a funny one-liner
you know so what'd you go with
you know what I actually don't remember
because it wasn't funny and I couldn't
think of anything oh not like other
girlies that's cute but like the end log
era is almost over so I'm gonna have to
come up with something else yeah let me
think for you
I'll sound off in the comments for
anyone who's a good idea for what I
should make my bio like it used to be
like talk [ __ ] for a living my Claude
with no job bio is facetune fan page and
I think that's funny and I'll never
change it
um but I'm constantly feeling uninspired
when it comes to Instagram bios it's
really hard yeah what about
mcclurgia's page
yeah that's that's definitely on my on
the short list of contenders I actually
was thinking about changing my bio soon
too
what's yours Big Time Magazine editor
it's so good yeah now I'm 30. I have to
keep it oh literally literally
okay our first story some really sad
news Aaron Carter the musician and
former Child Star has died at the age of
34. Aaron Carter the former Child pop
star known for his album's Aaron's party
and love has died people confirmed ntmz
was the first to report the news he was
34 years old the musician was found dead
Saturday morning at his house in
Lancaster California a spokesperson for
the Los Angeles County Sheriff's
Department told people that a body that
was discovered just before 11 A.M the
police initially did not officially
identify the victim a rep for Aarons has
declined to comment but noted a
statement will be released short I mean
by shortly by the family and management
at the time and since then his family
members have put out tributes Nick put
out something on Instagram as did
Aaron's twin sister Angel and last night
the Backstreet Boys had a concert in
London where they paid many tributes to
Aaron it was very emotional
it's so sad you know I feel like
especially because I was just like
watching and reading a lot about Matthew
Perry who's like a huge advocate for
um addiction I just feel like over the
last couple of years we've just like
watched Aaron Carter like Spiral
um like from afar and in a way when I
heard this like it's so sad and it's so
shocking because he's so young but
knowing he's been dealing with this it
like wasn't that surprising
um and it's just really sad and I
believe that Nick Carter they also lost
a sister to addiction
so um
and I know that they had a very strained
relationship I think um I don't think
they've even spoken in many years and I
think that's the case for a lot of
people whose siblings deal with
addiction
um like you don't know how to help them
and and they write you off and and you
just have to wait for them to come to
you and unfortunately that like wasn't
able to happen for Nick and Aaron and
it's really sad yeah and I saw all the
tributes I did think it was like a
little bizarre that the Backstreet Boys
didn't cancel their concert not to be
Shady but to each year around everyone
Grieves in their own way I agree
um but maybe given that they hadn't had
a relationship in a long time I know
still perform and then like grape
afterwards yeah I mean he broke down on
stage like many times like he was
clearly like it's okay to cancel shows
yeah
so um it's just so sad like so sad so
young I think so many of us
have like a memory like for me it's
Aaron's party like that song I still
know every single word I think a lot of
people like fell in love with him when
he was Lizzie McGuire's first kiss and
then a lot of people shared um Hilary
Duff's statement to Aaron because they
like had dated and they were like you
know teen icons they were we all have
like Associated like childhood memories
with him and it's really sad yeah she
had posted I'm deeply sorry that life
was so hard and that you had to struggle
in front of the whole world you had a
charm that was absolutely effervescent
boy did my teenage self love you deeply
sending love to your family at this time
rest easy I think that's an absolutely
beautiful statement
um for someone who knows him
right and I think like she Hillary kind
of like speaks for all of us because
like we all wanted to be Lizzie McGuire
when her first kiss was in Aaron
Carter's dressing room like so also
wasn't that I think Carter the guy that
like came like was the reason why like
Hillary Duff and like Lindsay Lohan they
like fought over him right oh did they
yeah
oh that's funny no I don't remember that
but like it's entirely possible that
that was the case
um it's just it's really sad yeah it is
really sad that's like the only thing
that you can say um
um
I also didn't know that the Backstreet
Boys were still like on currently on a
tour like I know that they reunite a lot
and they they're always in Vegas and
Like Doing I Heart Radio stuff but
they're like work they're working band
yeah no that's I was actually having
that same thought because I'm when I saw
all the the tributes I'm like oh I guess
I didn't realize they were on tour and I
just then started thinking about how
they're like they're pretty much like
eternally on like a reunion tour do they
put it I feel like they put out like
singles here and there but do they put
out new albums and stuff
I don't think so like I think they play
the hits like kind of how what's that
band that Donnie Wahlberg is in New Kids
on the Block like they're always doing
like cruises and Arena tours for like
their OG fans they don't like do they
don't do any more than that they don't
try and get new fans with new music they
just like have this really kind of
insane core fan base and they make a
great living off of touring all around
the world and without like ever doing
more yeah it's interesting so they play
yeah and I I was just thinking about
them in comparison to in sync because
that was like the you know the division
of our childhood was were you an insync
or a Backstreet Boys girly and if you
would have told me that like you know 25
years later the Backstreet Boys would
like still be touring and none of the
members of instinct would still be
talking to one another like I would cry
you know yeah also it reminds me do you
see this weekend that the Spice Girls
four out of five were reunited for
Jerry's birthday and they were like no
giving everything let me guess who
wasn't there I think it was Mel B I
didn't see her in the pictures oh but
maybe she was there and she just I
didn't see that Mel B is Scary
Spice yes so maybe she was one of their
there weren't that much there wasn't
that much stuff that came out yet but
like there were a few videos like they
played Spice Girls on the dance floor
and the girls were dancing together
singing like giving everything that's so
cute I would have assumed Posh wouldn't
go no she was this everywhere like
giving everything
um giving you away and that was the song
that was playing
so into it and David was on the floor
too
David was on the floor David was on the
Dance Floor I got a credit
um [ __ ] be with you for highlighting
this I would have never seen it I love
that Instagram account obsessed um also
like the Beckham's had a big weekend
because Nicola and Brooklyn hosted a
party like a very small party at their
apartment for her house for Selena Gomez
to congratulate her on her documentary
and I was just shook like I don't know
how those two know each other
yes I was shook to see that too Brooklyn
like cooked up some stuff for the girls
not him LARPing as a chef again Nicola
said the food was amazing of course of
course I actually watched a reel of him
making fish and chips recently and he
made a funny joke because he really he
made like he fried the fish and he made
his own french fries for the sandwich
like he sliced the potatoes he fried
them everything and then he put all of
it onto on two slices of bread to make
the sandwich and this bread was untosted
and so
um he made the caption like
the headline Brooklyn uses like can't
even toast bread
that's funny
um I do like when people like play into
what people say about them online yeah I
would have tried his fish and chips
no I really don't [ __ ] with fish and
chips I feel I think I would like it
what's not to like first God Must Have
Spent A Little More Time On You
that's so nice of you to say was that in
singer Backstreet Boys unexpected
was that in sync or Backstreet
Backstreet Boys because it's good
okay I'm like staring at
um my camera and I'm like almost 100
sure like I'm hella slanted there's a
chance I am too we had to rearrange our
setups today to go from two to one
unlike when two become one and
it it could be I'm looking at it looks
fine this is what I was saying the image
I see looks fine the lens is crooked
yeah no I'm just seeing like a crazy
Vivid visual but you know what we'll
figure it out in post we'll figure it
out in post
so that's what the Spice Girls were up
to this weekend
and really like sending well wishes to
the Carter family I feel like they've
been through a lot and that's really sad
yeah incredibly sad next story Selena
you gotta keep an eye out for Selena
because she's hitting back but I gotta
keep an eye out for Celine or I wonder
if she even knows about that lyric 100
she does is it something in popular
culture that other people say and post
office yes oh okay it's a tick tock
sound oh amazing like if anybody ever
posts like something like their kid has
like one eye open people are gonna be
like oh he's keeping an eye out for
Selena amazing I love that for everyone
Selena Gomez hits back at Francia Race's
reaction to her Taylor Swift comment
Selena hit back at Francia after the
actress commented interesting quote she
said interesting on a post highlighting
Gomez's statement about Taylor Swift
being her only friend in the industry so
okay they're like making this and
confusing news e-news posted a quote
that Selena had said in an interview
that like you know she's not really made
for this life and like so many of the
people you meet yada yada and really
Taylor Swift is like her only true
actual friend in the industry Francia
Risa commented and quickly deleted
interesting being like well I'm a
celebrity and we're friends friendly
enough that I gave you my kidney like
interesting whatever interesting
so everyone was all up in arms because
then everyone realized that Francia
doesn't follow Selena Gomez on Instagram
anymore and she hasn't for quite some
time but Selena still follows Francia
yes then
like I think someone was recapping this
situation and Celine on Tick Tock Selena
commented sorry I didn't mention every
person I know
okay so I want to say that
that the Tweet the the quote from Selena
about Taylor Swift like really had
nothing to do with Francia like I think
that it wasn't like an intentional dig
at Francia but like Francia
was probably still reeling over the fact
that she was completely completely
unmentioned in the documentary they
glaze over the kidney transplant and
they put a picture of like a tabloid
that has a picture of Francia and Selena
and it says Francia Selena doesn't utter
a word about Francia about the fact that
her friend was a match
um
and understandably like that is
upsetting to Francia so francia's like
definitely reaching being like this is
rude because like she was just making a
statement like it's not about you but
it's the fact that either they're not
friends
um which is weird if one gave the other
a kidney or it's the fact that yes
you're trying to say something nice
about Taylor but the fact that I didn't
even it didn't even cross your mind and
I am in the industry and I am your
friend and I did give you a kidney also
says a lot
no but then Selena's response this
comment is so rude
and so dismissive and like Beyond in my
opinion like
this [ __ ] gave you a [ __ ]
kidney she could really say whatever the
[ __ ] she wants and you have to oblige
like you do yeah
it's not I mean like she just said
interesting by the way
right no like Selena really is so wrong
for this and I have long thought there's
something so bizarre to me about this
kidney situation like how these two
became friends like we only found out
they were even friends after the kidney
was given then they were like never
spotted together again now this like I
have so many questions when it comes to
the the kidney transfer and now people
like are pulling up like interviews that
Francia has done talking about the
situation where it's like she doesn't
even seem like all that happy to have
done it you know she's telling the story
of the she knew she was a match
and she didn't tell Selena yet she like
was processing it
um and then I guess like the doctor told
Selena which I feel like is like a HIPAA
violation and Selena called Francia was
like oh my God you're a match and
Francia like had known and was waiting
to tell Selena her decision and then
felt you know
like kind of awkward on the phone
um so it doesn't feel like even at the
time when they were quote unquote
friends like it was really like a
like a good situation two things one
that's literally that episode of curb
where Larry gives his kidney to um
Richard
yeah two
how do and why did how did it go where
Brian see I even got tested for Selena
like if they're just like friendly
that's the thing so the documentary we
know nothing we literally know nothing
so the ancillary information we know
makes no sense like how many people got
tested for Selena
like her close friends and family
so they were close friends
I guess
and now they are not
I guess though a kidney was given
right and that raises questions and
here's the thing this is my issue a
documentary is supposed to answer
questions and from what I'm seeing a lot
of questions haven't been answered and a
lot of situations that were really big
have been glazed over or not mentioned
at all and that's just not the point of
a documentary that's going to be like
really
ex getting into everything
so that was my general takeaway from the
documentary it was like I was expecting
to walk away with like Clarity and like
Selena being like 100 transparent about
everything because that's the point if
you're not gonna and celebrities don't
owe us their truth like they don't they
don't know it's a documentary
no but if you're putting together a
documentary like I expect the the full
the full truth the full monty the whole
truth and nothing but the truth
my general like
overall takeaway was I don't feel like
this really cleared anything up
um not only pertaining to the kidney but
to her whole you know crisis in 2016 or
2017.
um I didn't feel like I walked away with
a clear understanding of what actually
went down and you know there have been
many rumors about what happened to her
during that time she canceled the
Revival tour and then like went into
hiding and
she had some sort of nervous breakdown
there has never been an actual clear
explanation as to what happened there
were a lot of rumors that it had to do
with the breakup with Justin there was a
lot of rumors that it had to do with the
abuse of alcohol or drugs allegedly and
then there was also the rumors about her
mental health and she alluded to those
rumors you know she kept in the
documentary putting Paparazzi footage of
her during that time where she canceled
the tour and there was you know
Paparazzi being like Selena are you
drinking Selena is this about Justin
Selena are you having a nervous
breakdown and they never answered those
questions
so
the the documentary did explain that you
know she had a a full mental nervous
breakdown psychosis
um
during that time and sought treatment
but they didn't explain if any of the
other things that people heard going
around were true or not did it have to
do with Justin did it have to do with
some sort of addiction none of that was
discussed and a lot of the fodder online
as it pertains to Francia is that part
of their friendship dissolution had to
do with the fact that Francia gave
Selena a kidney and then Selena
continued to do some of the behavior
that was bad for her kidney like
drinking alcohol
yeah so none of that was cleared up for
me and
everyone is obsessing over Raquel
so Raquel is Selena's friend who's a
huge part of the documentary she goes
with Selena everywhere she I literally
assumed she was a paid employee she's
not everyone in Selena's life is a paid
employee except for Raquel Raquel is a
friend
um and a lot of people are like Raquel
is toxic she's such a bad friend her and
Selena like fight a couple times like
they just like meant like they have like
little verbal arguments
um and everyone's like Selena needs to
cut Raquel out she's so toxic yada yada
and I'm like really that was not my
takeaway my takeaway was that Raquel is
literally the only person in Selena's
life who's not on her payroll therefore
can have an honest conversation which he
thinks Selena is acting in a certain way
because that's what friends do
um
and honestly I was really shocked by the
way everyone in Selena's life like
cuddles her and like they do everything
for her like they wake her up in the
morning like she really didn't seem like
she had any Independence
um and maybe that's like the best thing
for her after her you know struggles
with mental health but it just felt like
everyone in her life is on the payroll
managers assistants makeup artists so
everyone is just like telling her what
they want to hear and Raquel is the only
[ __ ] who like really has
nothing to gain other than just like
being a good friend and did she say
everything she needed to say in the
perfect way no but like that's what
friend does no I just I didn't think it
was like that crazy especially given the
fact that like it's a nice balance when
everyone else in your life is just
telling you what you want to hear right
and also everyone else in your life if
they are on your payroll they need you
to work so yeah they're waking you up
which maybe like might be helpful if
you're in a hard place mentally to do
this and to do that but maybe you
shouldn't be doing this and doing that
but that doesn't work for them if they
need to get paid so it's so important to
have people in your life who aren't
being paid I mean I think that's what
most lay people experience but we see
this with celebrities at different
degrees I mean the highest degree I
think is Brittany you know and it's
giving that sort of energy where like
everybody needs this person to work and
we're not going to listen to her body to
her mind to her wants and needs because
they conflict with what we want and what
we need
a hundred percent and
another thing that like I took away
which was like if this was my
documentary and I was like watching the
Final Cut like I would have asked for
like a few scenes to be taken out
because I just look rude
um like she she goes to uh London and
Paris to do promo and she hates doing
promo and I get it it's like a million
interviews in one day being like what's
your favorite dog
one way to answer yeah like Bruce and
she's acknowledging like how stupid it
is and how it's like she's putting out
meaningful work meaningful music
meaningful content and like in order to
get it seen she has to go to London and
like sit and be like you know
oh what color is your childhood
toothbrush like I get it but like the
way she's like low-key is so rude to
like the people that like are doing the
interviews and like work I just like I
would never have kept that in because
like I get it she's she's oh she's
constantly struggling she's never doing
what she wants to do except when she
went to uh Africa she was like so happy
because she loves doing philanthropy but
any other time she is upset at what
she's doing she is never doing what she
wants to be doing and I don't know what
she would prefer to be doing but she
doesn't want to do promo she like she
she's just always unhappy with what
she's doing because she and she said
like she hates being famous so why is
she doing it because the people around
her are making her no because she feels
this
obligation
having this platform and having been
through what she's been through to like
raise awareness about mental health her
dream is to like have a like in the
public school system like have the
government have like some sort of mental
health curriculum as a part of schooling
and like she met with the White House
like she's doing that but in order to do
that she has to keep doing the other
stuff like music and the idiot idiotic
stuff to like put her platform even
bigger
but you don't think that she's reached a
level like she has she's one of the top
five most followed people on Instagram
like you don't just lose that influence
when you don't put out a new album or
you don't put it like she's there and
she's permanent like yeah no I agree but
I feel like no one around her will tell
her that because they need her to work
yeah mental health advocacy isn't going
to pay their bills right exactly no it
was really like eye-opening but not in
the way I think the documentary intended
for it to be
um it just left me with like this
overall sadness for Selena like I think
she's deeply unhappy like I and I didn't
see any time in the documentary except
when she was in Africa where she felt
happy yeah and like that's a sad way to
live yeah
okay I'm gonna watch it so that I can if
I have anything there was one other
thing I wanted to say
hold on something important
oh
so the documentary had footage from like
2016 when the Revival tour started um
and I actually really liked that because
I have real like I had genuinely
forgotten how like in 2016 2017 like
Selena Gomez was that [ __ ] like her
music was everywhere it was everything
she had like like the footage was like
really hyping her up and I just like
forgot about that era for her because I
feel like she's been so tied to like
Justin and the Haley like I forgot that
like right out of Disney like she was
this sensation this pop star and it was
like this iconic tour and she was like
fabulous it girl I just forgot about it
and the footage was really like
reminding me and it was like hyping it
up but it just makes me sad because I
feel like no one who experiences that
like
every or most people who experience it
like
the fall after like it just gets so bad
afterwards which just makes me think
like that level of sickening and you
know Fame doing it all like is not
natural and that you can't I it's hard
to see someone who has all that and also
like
peace of mind and no that's true peace
of mind and happiness
no that's because you think about like
Britney and her Haiti like I remember
watching a concert of her like when I
was a kid and like the way she was
dancing like she was just like sickening
she was it girl yeah and it's like
maybe it's not supposed to be that way
because it feels like you can't have one
without the other
no it's so true like
yeah no that's really well put I know I
but I don't know I I don't know maybe it
could be that way but it's these
elements that make no I think there are
there are definitely people who reach
that level of Fame and everyone
struggles but they maintain their sanity
and they maintain a level as much as you
can of like being grounded like I think
Taylor Swift is a good example of that
yeah but I think that's once in a
lifetime I think
you have to literally like keep your
pre-fame friends and family like so
close to you I think it's it's possible
but it's very difficult yeah and I
wonder what the like differentiating
factors are and one of them is being a
child star one because your stuff did at
the age that you and like you you don't
know anything else you don't know how to
revert back to like who you used to be
to you don't really have pre-famed
friends because you made your friends
like throughout your life and you were
always famous Taylor Swift even though
she got famous pretty young like she
went to high school she had friends she
had a
normal experiences that I think have
helped Usher her through this like huge
Fame and I think a lot of it has to do
with your family what is so where is
super close with her mom and her stepdad
and her cousin she goes back to Grand
Prairie Texas a lot I was thinking that
too because
oftentimes like
being disconnected from your family can
can like if you're spiraling like it
makes it worse
um no she's super tight with her family
um I think what it also boils down to
and I feel like the Kardashians are
saying like always saying this like some
people are really made for that life and
some people are really not and I think
Selena can acknowledge like she was not
meant to be this famous like it's not
what she was
made to do but also I think the child
star element of it is really interesting
especially like I think the way Selena
grew up in the way Taylor grew up is
very different like I think for a long
time like after Barney and stuff Selena
was the sole um
earner
in her family like she grew up to a she
grew up with a single mom who was like
working a million different jobs and
then you know relatively quickly what is
she like 13 14 when she starts on Disney
she's making the money for the family
so that is like a really
um complex Dynamic to throw in yeah and
then people get used to a certain level
of living that like you can only reach
when you are having those big jobs
yeah yeah and then I think again it's
really nefarious when so like you have
your family and then the family are Bad
actors and I think that's like Britney
so she's a child star yes she doesn't
have people she can trust and the people
she should be able to trust are acting
nefariously and like that is just
you know but that's not the case at all
for Selena actually one of the parts
that I was like really moved by was you
know she was talking about how like when
she was really going through it mental
health-wise like she would have these
like breakdowns and she would say like
the most horrible evil [ __ ] to her
family like her mom and her stepdad and
like they never once turned their back
like they understood that like this was
just par for the chorus with someone
who's going through this
um and she still feels like she carries
so much guilt and sadness for like the
[ __ ] that she said
um to the people who were closest to her
and like who still never turned their
backs on her so um I do feel like she
has her mom was in the documentary and
her cousin Priscilla
wow okay I'm gonna check it out
yeah
are you ready for our next story which
actually
um
might spark a similar conversation
well is it the next story that might
spark a similar conversation that's
sponsored by fashion pass yes
we know so many toasters already know
and love fashion pass but it is truly
the steeniest clothing rental service
you'll get unlimited rentals for one
flat price and if there was ever a time
to sign up for fashion pass this is it
so many events holidays holiday parties
that you need outfits for and fashion
pass has you covered you want to look
sickening everywhere you go but that
gets expensive when you want a new
outfit for every event why spend 200 on
one outfit when you could rent unlimited
pieces for just 39 you have so much
you're saving so much money because
you're not buying clothes all the time
which is also just better for the
environment it is more sustainable and
clothing rental is a no-brainer but I
feel like a lot of the popular clothing
rental services are just buggly it's a
great idea like can I get some cute
clothes it's just like ugly crap
um but fashion pass carries like really
sickening Brands really contemporary
Brands like for love and lemons free
people show me your MooMoo Amanda up
Richard like stuff that's being sold
right now on revolve you can also rent
on fashion pass the trendsetter plan
that's what Jackie and I are both on
you'll get four clothing items or they
could pick three items and two
accessories for every order you can
switch out your items as many times a
month as you want so it's not like you
have to wait a whole month before
sending it back and if you're not into
renting and you just want to purchase
something you can actually buy anything
on their site now even if you're not a
member it's basically like Poshmark but
better because everything is in like new
condition and it's so easy to browse the
site for whatever you're looking for
they offer free shipping and returns
it's super easy and you can purchase
brand new items or like new items for
huge discounts up to 70 off which is
amazing and we have a special discount
code for you today it is their biggest
discount ever if you go to
fashionpass.com use code toast at
checkout you get 50 off your first month
so you can try it for just 39 that's
unlimited rentals for just 39 with code
toast at fashionpass.com today's episode
is also brought to you by bowling Branch
the holidays are the most exciting time
of year and if you want to enjoy them to
the fullest you need to get your best
sleep every night and it's easier than
it sounds because all you need is the
softest most luxurious organic cotton
sheets from Bowling Branch they are made
from the finest 100 organic cotton
threads on Earth and they make a
difference that you can truly feel night
after night we are bowling Branch girls
our entire houses are bowling Branch we
both have the signature hemmed sheet
collection my throw blanket we both have
the same throw blanket I have it in blue
and it's the thing I get like the most
questions on on Instagram people are
always asking me where my throw blankets
from it's like so cute and Chic great
gift for someone also just like for
yourself
um bowling Branch products are made
differently they are made from 100 of
the finest organic cotton on Earth so
you are sleeping better at night and
staying cool that's a huge problem for
me is sweating during my sleep they're
also free from toxins pesticides harsh
chemicals and they're made by Artisans
who earn the pay and respect that they
deserve you can give the gift of a
better night's sleep with bowl and
Branch right now our listeners can get
early access to their Black Friday sale
with promo code toast that's 25 off your
first set of sheets and free shipping
when you use promo code toast at bowl
and branch.com that's
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
toast that offer ends November 27th so
that's bowl and branch.com promo code
toast
b-o-l-l-a-n-d b-r-a
nch.com promo code toast offer ends
November 27th thanks clard
you're welcome next story an angry
Jessica Simpson is clapping back at
haters after her Pottery Barn ad video
went semi-viral Jessica Simpson says
she's feeling angry and defensive over
common she received on her now viral ad
for Pottery Barn the star posted a video
of herself passionately singing along to
her song party of one with an emphasis
on the line I don't give a [ __ ] about
you so she posted this video of herself
singing along to her own song party of
one which came out alongside open book
and she said I needed to be in my studio
today because this is where I ground
myself and heal as much as I've learned
to block out destructive noise people's
comments and judgments can still hurt
deeply with their incessant nagging you
will never be good enough
she noted that she's five years sober
from alcohol and through the Journey she
learned that she can get through any
battle that comes her way no matter what
trolls say quote I am capable of pretty
much anything I care enough to put my
mind to I am present I am deeply
inspired I am determined I am honest I
care about other people
so let me just say
Harry Barn video and I did raise an
eyebrow
um only because I love Jessica and it
was out of genuine concern I would never
comment like what's wrong with her like
people are so disgusting and moronic but
I love Jessica deeply and I read her
book and I know about her struggle so
when I saw that like of course it just
it concerned me that's all
um I didn't make a public statement
about it because I'm not a freak but I
did just you know raise my eyebrows
her assuring us that she's doing well
like great great she doesn't owe us that
but it did kind of put some of my
concerns to rest I love Jessica I just
want the best for her
um
and she she just was like
looking different in the video and like
like slurring a little bit yeah people
were concerned about her speech and her
weight and but like addiction like by
the way her weight didn't concern me
because she talked about in her book
like she is a girl who fluctuates like
she struggled like what's more relatable
than that like extremes on both sides so
like her weight didn't necessarily
um like trigger anything for me because
I feel like I know a lot about her and I
know that like her weight is something
that's constantly changing
um
it was more so like the the slurred
talking and like the kind of hazy Vision
um
but and that's what I learned from
Matthew Perry is like even post
addiction your addiction can take a
physical toll on you yeah on how you
talk on just like how your body
functions normally so that could be it
too I I just I was you know concerned
yeah I agree I'm glad she's coming on to
tell us that you know she's fine she
she's fine I think that is what she's
saying I think she Melissa was like
coming for the haters because I think
people were probably nasty and how they
were quote unquote concerned for her I
just with all my heart that she's doing
well and
I love that song that she was playing
and singing I love that song so good the
song so she put out songs along with her
audiobook for open book you had to buy
the audiobook in order to get access to
those songs initially so they never like
have any radio moments or anything like
that but they're so good
yeah no I love that she's like not
marketing her music like she's just
releasing it like it's really like a
passion of hers like a way to express
herself but it's not really even her
business anymore like her business is
being like a lifestyle fashion girly
yeah
I love that for her I have her
rollerblades and I actually have like a
ton of her shoes oh yeah we got the
rollerblades they were sick
they were sick
um so I like one thing about me if you
ever want to know what's on my mind it's
Eternal peace and happiness for Jessica
Simpson like I just genuinely want the
best for her agreed
and that's all that is all our next
story Bethany Franco will be revisiting
the housewives in a new re-watch podcast
three years after leaving the Real
Housewives of New York City the skinny
girl Mogul is putting the real back in
Real Housewives as she says with a new
rewatch podcast produced by iheartmedia
the show will be called rewives the
first installment of which premieres
November 14th it will see Bethany
watching iconic episodes throughout the
Bravo franchise's history like scary
Island from Roni the dinner party or
party From Hell from Beverly Hills the
hugun check me boo episode of Real
Housewives of Atlanta and the iconic
iconic table flip season one finale of
The Real Housewives of New Jersey each
week Bethany will be joined by
unexpected thought leaders and
celebrities like Elizabeth moths Jerry
Springer Suze Orman Kevin Nealon Dave
Portnoy Griffin Johnson Marin Morris and
more
I think conceptually as a podcast this
is a great idea like Housewives podcasts
really do perform very well in the
podcasting space
um
and the concept of like re-watching
iconic shows with people who you
wouldn't expect but are big Housewives
fans like I think it's great I just
think the selection for Bethany is
really
um it's losery because I feel like
Bethany in the last couple of years has
really made her bones off of like being
so shady towards Housewives
um
and then to kind of come back is like
it's it's lizery I actually think that
this is the shadiest thing she can do
towards Housewives because it's saying
the show is over and now we're gonna
re-watch the iconic moments it's like
nothing that like you do a re-watch
podcast for something that that's ended
and you want to relive it and the fans
want to relive it because it's over and
we have nothing left and so her doing
this is her saying the show is over so
let's go back and enjoy the great
moments
wow that's interesting I didn't see it
that way but I do totally see that now
um you know Danny Pellegrino was doing
an interview with Luanne last week and
he like knew that this news was going to
come out and so he was like by the time
this episode comes out like I think the
news will come out that Bethany's
hosting like a re-watch show called
rewinds and he reads the whole thing and
he gets luanne's like Luanne did not
know when he gets luanne's like live
reaction and she was like she basically
said what I said like you're literally
have made a career in the last few years
off of like putting all of us down
distancing yourself so much like from
the house so I was like you're too good
for it and she's like I just think it's
funny how now you know you're back yeah
she said that means she's going to [ __ ]
on us and her little podcast about the
housewives it's pretty sad and pathetic
that she has to resort to Housewives
because of all of her failed pivots
since the housewives she's tried
everything other than Housewives and it
doesn't seem to work and now she's going
back to Housewives
I just want to say Luanne is not wrong
about that except where Bethany has had
success is in being like a tick tock
talking head slash like almost troll
um
but you know she did the big shot with
Bethany never renewed she did do like a
few things afterwards
um and really the only space she's like
had success in his social media like
podcasting Tick Tock things like that so
she's not wrong I
I mean I feel like Bethany exceeds most
as a housewife because like she has this
big personality that works well like in
this Ensemble show but I feel like on
her own like she's had so much success
like she still is so relevant we have a
headline every week about like what
Bethany is saying about this or what
Bethany saying about that and like she
people love her she has a huge fan base
I
I would always like for her to come back
to Housewives I don't I mean I don't
read everything she says so maybe at one
point she was [ __ ] on housewives and
then she comes back with her tail
between her legs but the idea that she's
hosting this re-watch thing like to go
over like to enjoy and explore the thing
that made her famous like I don't think
it's so crazy or losery
I think it's like a little a little
a little because also she does have a
podcast that if it was going great like
you don't need a second
right right but good call
she's interesting we'll see I mean we'll
see how it goes yeah Carol also like
tweeted her thoughts which are all
negative
yeah no like the I think that's how I
actually found out about it because like
Carol's tweet had went
somewhat viral yeah so interesting but
to me it's her saying the show's over
now let's go relive it
yeah no that's that's an interesting way
of looking at it for sure are you ready
for our fifth and final story
the final story
It's the final story
30 flirty
and driving
thank you
our fifth and final story is a little
unlikely friendship news
a little unlikely friendship news a
little ufn ufn with a Sprinkle of Royal
news
Queen Elizabeth and Tom Cruise became
secret friends before her death
Queen Elizabeth was tickled okay no was
tickled pink to make another pal in the
world I got sent you a story about a
person that I never heard of
okay and you said people have you said
this is a backup story and I said it's
optional option if you if I need it but
and I didn't because I obviously needed
it no seriously seriously no you don't
want to hear about how they had tea
together and they had a secret special
friendship and that she was a big fan of
his Top Gun girly
no
wow no I know everything thank you why
because you've been doing this now
you've been putting a fifth and final
story that's Royal and you think I'm not
gonna notice because it's the end of the
show but it's like it's this isn't just
like the Queen's Bloomers are for sale
on a Friday when there's no other
stories like the queen and Tom Cruise
sparked up a friendship like that's
celebrity news
it happens to be royal news but it's
celeb news you're just being stubborn
because you heard the word Queen but
you're not being open-minded to the fact
that it's a suitable story
but why don't you tell everyone what
your what Your optional story was and
they can vote
Bella porch from Tick Tock is getting
divorced and it's like nobody even knew
she had a husband question mark
now vote sound off in the comments yeah
what sounds more interesting to you
let's talk about both then okay I'm
happy the queen made a friend yeah and
it was Tom Cruise your favorite guy so
he appeared as part of her Platinum
Jubilee celebration and Queenie was
plagued by mobility issues and unable to
meet him but she let it be known that
she was really disappointed not to have
met Tom at the pageant so he was invited
to have a very special tour of Windsor
Castle and with everything laid on for
him afterwards just the two of them had
tea together the visit was a success
with Tom given the chance to fire a
ceremonial gun The Source said she loves
seeing him and they really hit it off so
much so that she invited him back for
lunch he was even allowed to fly in by
helicopter however they were supposed to
continue with their lunch shape but it
wasn't to be as Queen Elizabeth passed
away on September 8th
very sad
it was nice unlikely friendship who'da
thought and you know what that's a plus
in the Tom Cruise column for me because
we're always Unsure how to feel about
him but if he was Queen no I feel like
I'm pretty sure
I feel like you love Tom Cruise honestly
you always [ __ ] say that dude I'm not
true no because you make such a point to
like slam him but I know that like
inside no because I feel like nobody
really like
everyone has separated like Tom Cruise
the movie star from Tom Cruise like the
crazy ass Scientologist and like I just
am here reminding people like it's the
same person okay
all right now the fifth and final story
uh bellaporch so Tick Tock star Bella
porch's entire life seems to be on
display to her 92 million followers yet
the fact that she's married is her best
kept secret until now anyways because
she is filing for divorce according to
legal documents obtained by TMZ dinari
porch which is her real name AKA Bella
filed docs in LA county to enter nearly
four-year marriage to Tyler porch The
Tick Tock star noted the standard
irreconcilable differences as the reason
that they're calling it quits but what's
interesting is that there are no photos
or videos of the couple on Bella's Tick
Tock or Instagram and there don't seem
to be any pictures of her wearing a
wedding ring the divorce documents say
that she and Tyler tied the knot in
January 2019 and if social media is any
indicator she seemed to be in good
spirits two days before getting married
posting for a mirror picture on
Instagram
so for those who don't know Bella porch
like had this one video go viral
um it was so dumb like it wasn't
anything it was like the sound m to the
b m to the B is m to the B yum like
whatever and Jake did this like cute
little head 92 million followers she's
like she walks in the Prada fashion show
she does Hugo Boss like it's actually
it should be studied because like nobody
knows anything about her
clearly I mean she's been in a
relationship for four years and nobody
[ __ ] knew so the fact that she's
married is so weird I remember like
people found out that like she was like
in the army
and not the American Army though I'm I
don't remember where she's from but like
she was in the Army for the her home
country and people were like
and it's like where oh and then like
for a while her videos were just her
face and then we saw our body and she is
like covered in tattoos like people were
just like we're like she's an ogre she's
an onion she's layered and now we're
learning she's married and it's like
what I mean honestly props to her for
like not telling the internet anything
about her personal life yeah
like it's it's admirable that's ideal
it's ideal because she's literally she's
on those lists she must be making
insane amounts of money so what does she
do now after that one video
like I don't even know she just like
I think she does like some like twitch
like gamer stuff
um she's the face of like a million
Brands she released a song that had like
a moment it went like
this same build a [ __ ] you you don't
get to pick and choose well I really
need a life
um and then she's just like always doing
[ __ ] she's like the face of Brands like
she's just always doing stuff got it
every time I open my Tick Tock it's like
more Bella porch brand of content she's
like she's like a Charlie but she's like
an international Charlie like Global oh
cool I'll check her out
yeah she must be one of the top maybe 10
or 20 most followed people she has more
followers than Addison
wow because she's more global
nice so those were the five and a half
five six
well it's Monday you guys deserve it
um really quickly I want to talk about
love is blind and if you have any TV you
want to recap
uh no I did not turn on a television
well the TV recap is brought to you by
Skylight frames the holidays are just
around the corner so if you're looking
for a good gift idea that your parents
are in-laws will genuinely love look no
further for really special gift for the
special people people in your life
you've got to check out Skylight frames
Skylight frames is a photo that you can
update instantly by email or from
anywhere
a great way to feel closer to those you
love when you're separated with a
skylight frame it is a digital frame
that you can send to I mean it's a great
gift for someone who's like not super
technologically savvy because it's super
easy to set up and you can do it all
from your email it's like a grandma a
mom an in-law it's so sweet you can
constantly be updating it with new
photos it's super easy everyone in the
family can use the app or they can just
use email to send them to the frame and
the pop-up in seconds multiple people
can send photos to the frame it's a
great way to keep large networks of
friends and families in touch it has a
black and white matte so it looks like a
real photo and it just adds a beautiful
touch to your home it's Timeless
um
it has a vibrant touch screen display
that lets you swipe through photos even
tap it a heart to let you know that the
person who sent it liked it you can
choose from two size options the
original 10 inch and they have a new one
now it's a large 15 inch frame and they
have 100 satisfaction guaranteed so if
you don't love the Skylight they will
offer you a full refund and you could
pre-load it with photos of special
moments for the perfect personalized
gift you can import pictures of you and
your significant other your spouse
grandparent and they it's the right way
to surprise someone with photos like
that they don't even know that you have
because you know everyone has like a
million I have like 40 000 photos on my
photo album and it's just a great way to
like remind people of great memories me
and Ben got it for his in-laws it was a
great gift they love it and every time
we add new photos to it they like plots
it's a really sweet it's a great way to
be like a great daughter-in-law
as a special offer you can get 15 off
your purchase of a skylight frame when
you go to skylightframe.com enter code
toast to get 15 off your purchase at
Skylight frame you have to go to
skylightframe.com code toast
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com promo code
toast skylightframe.com promo code toast
for 15 off of the Skylight frame really
such a great gift like a no-brainer it
really is like it's really thoughtful
yeah if you order one now you'll have
like a perfect gift for someone because
you will forget to get a gift for
someone and then you'll have a backup
Skylight frame
so love is blind again they're doing
like drops so this was the second to
last drop we got one of the weddings
um so we know about the fate of one of
the couples and so spoiler alert if you
haven't seen the Raven and SK wedding I
am about to spoil it
she was actually really interesting so
he is Nigerian and his family is like
very Nigerian they take the culture very
seriously they wanted a Nigerian wedding
and Raven is like this independent girl
who like she's like everyone like
thought she was like the hottest girl
there
um and everyone wanted her and even
after the pods like guys were being like
weird and creepy to her but she really
liked SK and she was very like hesitant
at first to like dive into Nigerian
culture but eventually like she really
got on board and they had this beautiful
wedding where they merged both the
cultures and she was like this hot thing
and like obviously SK was just like
happy to be with her you know and so she
really like fell in love with his mom
and it was really sweet and her family
like wanted no part of this like
television nonsense so like she was
really leaning on his family and they
get to the altar
and he says no why
I don't know
and it was so shocking actually his
mother went to the bridal Suite after
the wedding and was like apologizing
like she was like I really like you like
I wish it was actually very sweet the
connection that his mom and the bride
had made and I don't know why he said no
I mean it wasn't ideal like he's going
to grad school for four years in
Berkeley and this season they did it
based in Dallas so everyone lived in
Dallas
um and like she's just like this really
successful independent girly and like I
don't think she loves the idea of like
having a husband who was going to be in
the next four years like she would have
to financially support but like she was
down and she was like hysterically
crying afterwards and she was like I was
gonna say yes like I couldn't believe he
said no like I was genuinely shocked and
we didn't really even get a reason why
is there more to come or you're not
gonna get a reason
so then like then they moved on to the
second wedding but they didn't finish it
they left us on a cliffhanger we know
that
um Nancy and bartis
who said yes I think it was Nancy which
was like not the move on her part like
how many like he literally said a
thousand times since the pods like like
we're not physically connecting like
you're not my type like it's so rude
and he keeps acting like you would think
he's Brad Pitt like he's not like you
all these so many of the guys this
season have been saying to the girls
like you're not my physical like type
like you know I'm gonna try to make it
work because we have an emotional
connection like doing them a favor and
it's like dude you're [ __ ] ugly like
the way these guys they think they're so
[ __ ] hot I think that's like a a
testament though to like guys of this
generation in general like they really
think they're something when they're not
no but it's also like if you're not
capable of forming a connection with
someone who doesn't
um check off the physical appearance
boxes then you shouldn't go on this show
like if you're someone who's really you
know say physical and and that's fine
like really if that's how you are like
if say physical is 50 and then the
emotional connection is 50 then then you
shouldn't go on the show but if you're
someone who can identify like that you
really like are looking for a soul mate
and you don't even have such a specific
type if you did like but it doesn't even
really matter what it is then you should
go on the show like know yourself
no that's a really good point
so let me just make a prediction
for what's gonna happen with the rest of
the couples I actually do think Nancy
and bartise will get married and here's
why I think bartise is like thirsty like
I think he wants to be famous and I
think he's going to do everything he can
and Nancy said yes and if either one of
them should have said No it should have
been Nancy so I think they will get
married
I they're trying to make us think that
my girl Alexa like Jewish Queen who is
marrying like a country boy who's like
Jackie he'll do anything for her he was
wearing a yamaka he said a convert like
he is obsessed with her they've been
Problem free like we don't even see them
like they're my favorite couple and
they've been on the screen for five
minutes because they have no [ __ ]
problems they're trying to make it seem
like he shows up to the wedding and like
set cold feet no they're getting married
100 and like I'm obsessed
they're getting married Cole and zeneb
are not getting married
but I do think that Colleen
and I forgot his name Matt I think
they're gonna get married even though
like it actually really scares me
because I see him as like a walking red
flag a really mean guy and she's like a
really sweet like nice girl like who
just goes with the flow and I think like
I think it's a bad relationship like he
gets drunk and like packs his bags
because she went out with her friends
like psychotic you know people like that
like [ __ ] psychotic energy
I don't know all these people you'd be
surprised they fake it till the end like
no one could just break it up in the
middle of the show like
they all act like they really like this
person like that to me was the biggest
thing with like shake and deep tea like
the fact that no you're right I said no
when the whole season she was acting
like she didn't know about his the mean
things he was saying because she didn't
and but that like she was under her
spell and really loved him and like this
you would have thought that it wasn't
even a question but then it just turns
out they've been acting the whole time
because I guess either they can't go
home in the middle or then they're out
on some episodes no [ __ ] you're so
[ __ ] right like the way everyone is
acting like you think they're all
getting married and yeah and it's like
you actually have no idea what's about
to happen because they've been lying
this whole time
no you're right like they lie to us when
they live in the apartments like people
I think you can go home in the honeymoon
like remember Shayna bounds yeah but
nobody goes home in the apartments I
don't know if that's because like the
show is like you need to stay and so we
have a show or it's like well that's a
few episodes that I wouldn't be in I'll
be here no you're so right
so right so it's like of course we think
they're gonna get married because
they've been making us they've literally
been telling us that they are right so
it's like if you can actually see the
two people wouldn't get married it must
be really bad
yeah yeah
Colon's a knob they're not getting
married
yeah
okay
um so I think the final wedding episodes
come out on Wednesday and like literally
in this most recent episode and I will
be doing this on Wednesday too like
fully skipping till they're at the altar
because they're they literally spend 20
minutes on each couple they're playing
[ __ ] we've already [ __ ] seen I I
agree so annoying
so like with bartista and Nancy I was
literally skipping till yeah do you
that's where I go
they have a statement at the beginning
that gives no indication of whether
they're about to say yes or no yes
no they're just like really it's like
[ __ ] mind [ __ ] at this point
so that's what I was watching
um what's on tonight anything
I don't think so
no
but I got a lot of catching up to do on
other stuff so that we can recap this
week I will try and watch Selena
yeah I would love to know your thoughts
yeah I would love to share it I'd love
to know everyone's thoughts I would like
I'd love to have some thoughts and
please if you saw the documentary share
your thoughts in the in the comments I'd
be curious to know
that's our show
can you believe it it is
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast on Monday Morning Show where
we deliver the past five stories you
need to know every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that Spotify
iTunes teacher public radio I hear video
Kiss books all the places where we
listen to podcasts find us the toaster
leave a five-star review about how
wickedly talented we are hope you guys
have an amazing Monday we'll see you
tomorrow we'll see you tomorrow in
tomorrow's election day so either vote
before the toast or a vote after the
toast we'll remind you tomorrow go today
if you can but if you're someone who
like listens to the toast on your
commute home
so we would this is your reminder this
is a reminder for tomorrow because you
might not listen to tomorrow's episode
while the polls are still open
it is a privilege to vote and I'm proud
to be it I mean look at my spine [ __ ] I
should have worn this sweater yesterday
where tomorrow tomorrow wear it again
not okay
and I'm proud to be an American whoever
stand oh I'm free you know I won't
forget I don't want to actually make a
mockery of this song it's like no it's a
gorgeous um
have a great day everyone we'll see you
tomorrow bye